hey everyone welcome to yessi tv where
you can find weekly videos on minimalism
and healthy living to help you live a
simpler happier life
today i want to talk to you about
something that's a bit controversial and
it's
why i do not have social media i quit
social media about five years ago and i
do not see myself going back
so today i'm gonna share with you my six
reasons for why i quit in the first
place
and if you stick to the end you will get
my tips and tricks of things that i do
to maintain my relationships reason
number one
superficiality i had lots of
friends on social media but they felt
superficial and
fake not the individuals but the
relationships
they didn't know what my life was like
at home they didn't know that i faced
depression
and much less would they have known why
these were not the kinds of friendships
that i wanted i didn't want to have
500 friends but not have a single person
to talk to about
real life deep situations and what i was
actually going through and facing in my
life
fear of loneliness i mentioned in a
previous video
how i overcame social anxiety that i was
actually given a diagnosis
of social anxiety disorder having said
this
i was scared to talk to people but i did
want friends
that little facebook message alert
suddenly became addicting to me
i loved to see that little guy pop up
and i call it addiction
because i was happy when it was there
and sad and lonely when it wasn't
it was as if the more messages and likes
and friends i had
the more it meant people actually liked
me that maybe i wasn't a loser after all
this just made my social anxiety much
worse
i'm kind of nerdy so i have to share
just a tiny bit of an article that i was
reading
on the effects of social media and
mental health just stick with me
short one of the studies indicated that
internet use in general
significantly affects social
relationships
and participation in community life in
this research
authors found that increased time spent
online is related to a decline in
communication with family members
as well as a reduction in the user's
social circle
which may further lead to increased
feelings of depression
and loneliness and if you just search
the terms
social media and its effects on mental
health i bet you there are hundreds
of thousands of articles just like these
[Music]
validation i wanted to be
liked no pun intended i had to post just
the right picture at
just the right angle because it felt as
though the more likes i got the more it
meant people actually liked me
and for someone with very low
self-esteem it really only meant that i
was
spending hours a day scrolling through
pictures of
gorgeous people living perfect lives and
only putting myself down because
i wasn't living that way and i didn't
look the part
i didn't have the perfect lifestyle the
perfect family the perfect body the
perfect wardrobe
and for me it meant that i was
constantly feeling less than
others because i was seeking validation
from outside myself
as though others perceptions of me
mattered more
than what i perceived myself to be i
would spend
hours trying to take the perfect profile
photo
only to change it later on because it
wasn't good enough
have you ever been guilty of this one
let me know in the comments
missing out the fourth reason why i quit
social media is because i was missing
out on the world around me
five years ago on a beautiful fall
afternoon i caught myself on a
beautiful mountain top gorgeous view i
had never been there before
and i realized i had a problem when i
immediately my first thought when i was
there was
let me whip out my phone so i can take a
picture and post all about it
i didn't know how to be present in the
moment and enjoy the situation i was in
because i was constantly in this routine
of post
talk about it picture i was missing out
on amazing experiences because
my attention was focused on letting the
world know about it rather than me
enjoying it
escape one of the other reasons why i
quit social media is not only because it
was what i turned to
to face happy situations but it was also
a way to escape
negative situations in my life and this
is for several reasons
reason number one is i could avoid
stressful and negative thoughts and
memories
because it provided me with an easy
distraction reason number two
is i could avoid crucial conversations
with other people
because it was so much easier to message
them than actually speak to them face to
face
and for someone with social anxiety this
was perfect
it meant i didn't have to face my fear
of talking to people
face to face and reason number three i
could escape feelings of boredom
because it tricked me into thinking that
i was actually doing something even
though
not all too productive which leads me to
my last reason
lack of productivity i have a confession
to make
i used to follow the lives of the
kardashians and waste
hours of my time just following the
lives of reality tv stars
i don't know maybe if i watched enough
lives of millionaires i could become one
too
no the truth is we all have the same
24 hours in a day and i was done being
the consumer spending hours a day
consuming the information that other
people put out
i wanted to be more focused on how i
could be the producer
and how i could be a boss how i could
give a service to the world instead of
constantly just being a consumer once i
quit social media it
instantly increased my productivity
because it freed up hours of my day
that i could actually now invest in
myself and improving
my abilities and my knowledge base so
that i could accomplish the goals that i
had for myself
because before all that i didn't even
have goals to begin with
so between all of those things that i've
mentioned the fear of loneliness the
need for validation
the superficiality the easy escape
missing out and the lack of productivity
social media is just not for me
if you're interested in leaving social
media but you're afraid of how it might
affect your relationships
i've got three tips for you of things
that i do to kind of maintain and keep
up with your relationships
tip number one ask people for their
birthdays or any special events or
occasions or holidays that they
celebrate
and jot those down in your calendar and
make sure
that once they're there that you have it
to where it's recurring so that it will
remind you
to give them a call or to message them
on that day
preferably call them what better way to
tell someone happy birthday than to
actually give them a call
and wish them happy birthday i know for
me i have one friend that will
always call me on my birthday and even
if i don't answer she will leave a
message
and sing that song to me and it makes me
feel very special
tip number two is to actually call
someone once a week
you can do more frequently if you feel
like that you have time for it
but to actually schedule it in as
something recurring is a habit ingrained
in you is going to be
so much better at maintaining those
relationships
and i say call because this way
you can actually have a much more deeper
conversation
how many times has somebody passed you
on the street saying how
are you and you say good as they're
walking away from you
messaging can be very similar it can be
very superficial so pick up the phone
you can hear their tone of voice and
actually have a deeper conversation
lastly tip number three make sure you
contact people frequently or routinely
when you don't need something the last
thing that people want is to be that
person of
oh he's calling me because he needs me
for something
so make sure you're constantly looking
to serve others
and find out how they're doing and what
they're needing
rather than finding your needs met there
you have it guys my six reasons for why
i quit social media and why i do not
intend to go back if you like this video
please give me a thumbs up
and subscribe so that you won't miss out
on my weekly videos
i thank you so much for watching and i
hope to see you in the next one